les banques marquent contre la soirée
c'est bien évidemment la victoire de mr
aulas la magnifique on passe directement
au katla est passé aux 4 passes et aux
quatre la miss light i bon ou mauvais
choix
je suis fou de miss tahiti pas je vous
le dis je n'ai pas le temps de le dire
ce soir je suis fou de miss tahiti
ça n'est pas mon art est en jeu n'est
pas mon délire du crime non mais je
voulais rebours montrer son parcours
lors de la cérémonie de samedi
voilà ce que vous savez comment elle
s'appelle son prénom valhalla knights
est magnifique roman policier est très
sympathique fait un bel accent qu'elles
gardent l atout elle a tout pour elle l
avait laissé les autres aller loin et
j'ai une pensée pour miss guadeloupe de
la peau ah oui à chaque fois elle a même
pas et les chutes et les sauces à
l'escouade on prend ça mais je sais
d'elle elle était la première depuis le
jeu sa première dauphine cabinet la
rentrée chez elle à la presse évaluent
sa les parties en métro quoi donner son
accord
c'est la première nouvelle loi mais je
te dise les mesures n'est qu'à la fin
sur lui s'il vous plaît alors à la
pression qui s'attaquera les parties
tout le monde et à personne à parler
d'elle la pomme vanille est 4e et ben
c'est un score mais c'est un scandale
c'est vrai je suis assez d'accord
oui elle est première dauphine c'est la
plus mauvaise place mais oui là mais je
vous le dis c'est comme ici être
convaincus et de la base où viendront
dire m'appelle weimar hamas avait fait
24 ans et j'ai été et du nist haïti à
papeete
[Applaudissements]
j'ai longtemps été long de et c'est
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur de
partager aujourd'hui j'ai confiance en
moi et je m'accepte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais si tahiti
[Musique]
la statistique est magnifique les gueux
la sacristie à la vie ça précisément
millions celles millions soit au mauvais
choix derrière
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ou bon
choix l'a dit mon choix oui c'est une
loterie élections je vois loterie ou
encore à celle là pour construire alors
pourquoi des choses qui peuvent être
mille sources au moins elle est
magnifique comme les présidents de la
république et les colères non c'est une
très belle miss et je suis ravi ben
voilà quelle est la quatrième se
présente la france et qu'on puisse mal à
assumer ma qu'elle puisse assumer ses
formes et je trouve ça bien d'avoir une
miss et qui fait pas 1,3430 fois je
l'adorais l'adorent parfois je les ai
adorés dès le début et regardez on va
revoir son triomphe voilà sa victoire et
voilà ça devrait qu'elle utilise un mot
dont on avait été beaucoup plus si vous
aviez vous [ __ ] mais je peux pas le
dire parce que mon fils regarder son jeu
va lui donner des sous en malaisie je me
le dit un gros mot
oui moi j'avais dit ça vous arrive
bientôt et ut à yenne [ __ ] vous avez
dit papa tu fais au nom qu'elle ait
jamais eu qu'est ce qui t'arrive
regardez miss france 2009 et miss tahiti
[Musique]
vous pleurez besoin
vos impressions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et là et je vous dis benjamin actes et
lille valérie et bernard avait
pronostiqué la victoire de miss tahiti
c'était la grande grande favorite c'est
la 5ème miss tahiti être élu la dernière
c'était mareva galenter en 1999 à 18 ans
elle peser 80 qu'il ou elle a perdu 20
kg alain bac technologies de
communication un bts de négociation et
relation client une licence de droit
économie et gestion job c'est un master
24 cents épouse avait d'ailleurs sylvie
tellier 24 ans et cotonou et oui alors
limite merci alors c'est vrai que c'est
un bon choix
bref beaucoup ça peut prendre dit
mauvais soit bon parce que moi j'étais
outrée que la miss rhône alpes ne soit
pas finalement
ouais mais bon ça mais vous blandine
pompiers en plus japon s'est pas mis ce
grand déchet alors c'est quoi